Okay, so welcome back to the screen. We've
come to the end of leading indicators now
in the PTM video series. So let's have a
recap of what we've learned so far. This
is a very natural gap and natural time to
do a nice recap and to have a look at
where we've come from in the PTM video
series and where we're going.
So this will be very familiar to you now.
We have our leading indicator dashboard.
And of course, on the left hand side, we
covered early on in the video series, all
of our US leading indicators, our money
markets indicators, our surveys, and our
cyclical commodity prices. And we also
covered international leading indicators,
or at least some of them or the main ones,
that being the US leading indicators.
European economic indicators. And the
European economic sentiment indicator, and
the China manufacturing PMI official
versus CAICSIN in the category of surveys.
And we also covered in money markets,
China real interest rates. So further
work, obviously, for you guys, in your own
time, is to look at money markets in
Japan, UK, Germany, and Italy, and in
Italy.
Italy, and look at the bond indicators and
use the downloaded downloaded material to
cover those bond markets. That's further
work for you in your own time. And also
indicators that you should be following on
a weekly to monthly basis. Also, with
cyclical commodity prices, you have all
the downloads available for the main
international front month futures
contracts.
international commodities like Brent oil,
London metal exchange, and Shanghai
copper. Now it's always good at a time
like this, seeing as though we've covered
a lot of information, just to see a big
picture map of where everything that we've
learned fits in. So here, we have a time
lag chart, where we have our leading
indicators.
that we've covered the monthly reports
that we've covered so far, leading into
the monthly reported coincident
indicators.
And you can see on the left-hand side
under leading indicators. And you can see
on the left-hand side, under leading
indicators, what we've covered so far. So
money markets, both US and international,
surveys, US and international,
commodities, US and international, and
also stock markets and Forex. So Forex
would be our US dollar trade-weighted
index.
And the stock market. And the stock market
would be primarily the US stock market. So
the US stock market. So the US stock
market, but also international stock
markets. And we've included these under
leading indicators because they are
leading indicators in themselves.
For our coincident indicators, you'll see
that we have inflation in there, which we
covered earlier in the video series, when
we were looking at cyclical commodity
prices. And we know that CPI and PPI is
reported monthly, and that it's a
coincidence indicator.
So the US stock market is a coincidence
indicator. And we've got a coincidence
indicator. And if you go to the downloads
area for this video, you'll get a download
PDF, which includes all of the coincidence
indicators in the US explained and broken
down with sources.
Inflation, inflation is there. And so is
the employment situation report. Now the
employment situation report covers
something called non-farm payrolls, and
the unemployment rate, but also private
sector and government sector employment.
And non-farm payrolls is reported, as well
as the unemployment rate, on a monthly
basis, as part of the ESR, as part of the
employment situation report.
And non-farm payrolls is a very focused on
number by professionals in the stock
market, because it tells us the amount of
jobs that have been added to the US
economy in the last month. However, the
focus is definitely over-exaggerated in
financial markets, because we do actually
get something on a weekly basis, called
initial
initial and continuing jobless claims. So
we get jobless claims on a weekly basis,
and we get the ESR on a monthly basis. And
what the jobless claims number tells us is
on a weekly basis, how many people in the
United States are filing for unemployment
insurance.
So by the time we actually get to the
employment situation report, where that
tells us how many jobs have been added in
the previous month, so ESR is reported on
the first Friday of each month, and the
data is for the previous month. By the
time we get to that, we've had four weekly
jobless claims reports since the previous
ESR,
since the previous employment situation
report. And what that means is, is that by
the time we get to the ESR, there should
be no surprises by the market, and there
generally never is.
And what's funny is, is that it gets a
disproportionately large amount of
attention from the media in general. So
the ESR gets a disproportionately large
amount of media attention, and even sucks
in a lot of professionals to pay a
disproportionately large amount of
attention and importance to it.
But really, there should be no surprises
of what's going to happen to non-farm
payrolls and the unemployment rates on a
monthly basis, because we have weekly,
initial and continuing jobless claims.
And yes, of course, even the Fed is
watching jobless claims. So the Fed should
not be surprised by the non-farm payrolls
number either, nor the unemployment rate,
when it's reported on the first Friday of
every month for the previous month.
Now, all of this is explained in the
coincident indicators download PDF. Also,
you can get the non-farm payrolls data,
the unemployment data, you can get jobless
claims, initial and continuing in
spreadsheet downloads in the downloads
area as well.
So you can get to do further work on those
in your spare time. We've also included a
couple of more coincident indicators.
We've included durable goods and shipments
and industrial production, which is
reported monthly as well.
And you'll find those in the spreadsheet
downloads as well. Take a look at that
data, research it in the PDF, understand
what those numbers are all about.
Essentially, these are numbers that are
confirmation indicators. So the
coincidence indicators are confirmation
indicators of what our leading indicators
predicted in the past will happen in the
future.
And then on the right hand side, you can
see our lagging indicators, which are
reported quarterly and looking back over
the previous quarter. And what do they
include? Yes, that includes company
earnings and gross domestic product GDP
growth.
These are indicators that are reported
last and they are lagging indicators. So
our leading indicators forecast our
coincident or confirmation indicators and
our lagging indicators.
Our coincidence indicators give us
confirmation of what we saw in our leading
indicators in preceding months and our
lagging indicators tell us what happened
previously in the last quarter.
And what our leading indicators predicted
and what our leading indicators predicted
and our coincident indicators confirmed
prior to the lagging indicators actually
reported.
So how does this all fit together? Well,
prices of money markets, commodities,
stocks and forex are leading indicators in
themselves because they price in the
expectation of risk.
Now, prices of risk based on forward
looking projections of earnings and GDP
growth.
So for stocks themselves, this means their
changes in forward looking earnings or EPS
earnings per share growth. And leading
indicator surveys, which are obviously
part of our leading set, are reported
monthly, but they're a key driver of risk
sentiment and prices.
Because they are forward looking. And
prices of money markets, commodities,
stocks and forex lead coincident and
lagging indicators. Coincident and lagging
indicators essentially either confirm or
deny the market's expectations that are
embedded in the prices of the instruments
themselves.
So that's really important. So it's still
important to stay on top of coincident and
lagging indicators because essentially
coincident indicators are our confirmation
indicators and lagging indicators should
either confirm or deny what we've seen
throughout the time lag series going from
leading to confirmation to lagging.
Now, if you remember our time horizon and
volatility chart.
volatility chart from a trader's
perspective and from an investor's
perspective, this should, given the work
that we've done so far in the PTM video
series,
this should, given the work that we've
done so far in the PTM video series, start
to become a lot clearer as to why we exist
as traders and portfolio managers within
the 20 to 60 day time horizon.
So just think about it for a moment in
terms of leading indicators and prices. So
prices of instruments in money markets,
the stock markets, commodities and forex.
Think of that in terms of leading our
monthly and quarterly reports.
So, for example, if you pick a day right
now. So the day that you're watching this
video series and you say, OK, I have a
trade idea in a stock and I think I should
be buying this particular stock.
Well, what you're looking as part of your
analysis at is what's going to happen to
the future earnings of that company.
And that is affected by both macroeconomic
and microeconomic factors.
And their next earnings report could be up
to one quarter away from now.
So today's date, when we are entering a
position, we are looking for a stock to
actually perform before the earnings
report.
So we enter that position now. So in the
next 20 to 60 days.
So if we look 20 days ahead from now and
60 days ahead from now, that's the
volatility we want to be exposed to
because our prices are going to predict
the earnings report.
By the time earnings come out, we already
know that earnings are going up if we are
choosing to buy a stock.
And this is why you see so many times in
the market, for example, a stock that goes
up into its earnings report.
And then when the company reports better
than expected earnings, the stock either
goes sideways or goes down or even at the
macroeconomic level.
When, for example, the stock market goes
up into the jobs report number.
So the employment situation report.
And we get a better than expected non farm
payrolls number.
The market sometimes responds by going up
for the first one hour.
And then the market goes down afterwards
and even lower than it was previously on
the day or even goes down further than it
was on the week.
And essentially what is happening here is
that prices are leading the report
themselves that is reported on a quarterly
or monthly basis.
So prices are leading in themselves and
then we get profit taking because
everything is priced in once the report
cuts out.
It confirms what we already expected and
prices are reflecting the expectation of
the market.
And what's funny is is amateur traders or
retail traders and even a lot of
professional traders are guilty of this as
well.
When a company reports better than
expected earnings or non farm payrolls
comes out slightly better or better than
expected, short term traders like retail
traders and even professional day traders,
they will go into the market and they will
buy stocks or buy the market on the day of
those numbers.
And it's a big mistake because prices have
already run into the number and prices
already reflect the expectation.
And what these guys are actually doing is
they are providing liquidity for all of us
guys who operate in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon,
who predicted it already 20 to 60 days
previously.
And we took positions before the prices
moved.
And we are now getting out and those guys
are providing us with liquidity.
They are linked to the party.
And of course, when you see this time
horizon and volatility chart on the
screen,
now you better understand why we are not
one day or five day traders or one year to
five year investors.
We are operating in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon, trying to take advantage of one
to three month volatility and the move in
prices on expectation of what's coming out
in the next 20 to 60 days.
And also now you better understand why we
don't or try as hard as possible not to
exist in the gray area because trades
slowly become investments throughout the
gray area between the 60 to 120 day time
horizon.
So before 60 days, we are essentially
taking trading positions.
At 120 days and beyond, they are
definitely investments.
But on the journey from 60 to 120 days, a
trade is very quickly becoming an
investment.
And we are not investors.
We operate in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
And we are forecasting what's going to
happen 20 to 60 days from now.
And we're making sure that we take the
position now and prices move in 20 to 60
days.
And we are getting out around or before
the 60 day time horizon.
Now, as a reminder as well, our pro trader
systematic framework.
So if you recall this from earlier in the
video series, we have our theory and
implementation.
And of course, in a video series, we are
covering, of course, mostly theory.
And the theory that we've covered so far
in the PTM video series is the
quantitative process of macroeconomics.
And that is in the area of fundamentals.
And fundamentals, as mentioned previously,
at the beginning of the video series, is
the most important part of the overall pro
trader systematic framework.
This is what drives all of your trade
ideas, the quantitative and the
qualitative process.
So the IPLT video series literally proved
statistically where we should be
positioning ourselves as traders and
portfolio managers to maximize our
opportunity set via time horizon and
volatility analysis.
And our conclusion from the IPLT video
series to enable us to get consistency in
returns.
In returns, we need consistency in
volatility and consistency in opportunity
set and therefore ideas.
And that is the one to three month time
horizon.
And so far in the PTM video series, we've
been focusing on the top down
macroeconomic analysis of the quantitative
process as part of the overall pro trader
systematic process.
Which the PTM is designed in its entirety
to teach you.
So, so far what we've done is we've
engaged in a very thorough masterclass in
top down analysis of macroeconomics.
So, so in the future we generate a long or
short or neutral bias in our long short
portfolio.
Now, further in the PTM video series,
we're going to combine this with bottom up
fundamentals to generate long and short
biases for the overall stock market
sectors and individual stocks.
So, macroeconomic fundamentals.
So macroeconomic fundamentals, what do we
use them for?
Well, we use them to obtain a global macro
view on the stock market and a view on
geographical dispersion and expectations.
So, questions, for example, that we should
always be asking ourselves all the time.
Will global stock markets rise or fall in
their entirety?
Will the US, for example, outperform or
underperform the rest of the world?
Will Europe outperform the US and China
underperform both Europe and the US?
Well, we have to be asking ourselves these
questions all the time.
And as traders and portfolio managers, we
get the answers from our global
macroeconomic data.
And that's why we always have to be on top
of our leading indicators.
Now, what is the point of all this?
Well, professional traders understand that
money flows globally change given the
macroeconomic outlook, both geographically
between asset classes and within asset
classes themselves.
So, from a trading perspective, when the
entire stock market either rises or falls
because of macroeconomic factors, we not
only want to be in a position where we
don't lose money, we want to be in a
position where we make money.
We are absolute return traders.
We want to focus on that and make money
whether the market goes up or down and not
be concerned about measuring ourselves
against stock market returns.
We want to make money in all environments.
And this requires an understanding of
macroeconomics and using the leading
indicators to forecast the future.
And as a reminder why, we want to predict
which way the wind is blowing.
We want to know where the tailwind is to
enable not only our portfolio bias of
long, short or neutral, but also to make
sure we take advantage of the moves.
So, we're long the right stocks and we're
short the right stocks as well.
And of course, we always want to make sure
we're on top of our risk management.
So, when a macroeconomic factor changes,
we know what's going on, we know what it
means and we can adjust our portfolio.
So, for example, if you've been
experiencing this at any time in the
market in real time with real money, if
you've ever been in a situation in a bull
market where,
for example, you are long growth stocks
and the stock market falls suddenly by 10%
and your growth stocks go down 20, 30 or
40% and underperform the index move.
And there doesn't seem to be any reason
for it.
So, there's no, for example, stock
specific reasons for the moves of the
underperformance.
And most retail traders often have no idea
why this happens.
Well, it's usually because of a change in
macroeconomic expectations and
professional money managers reallocating
risk.
Everything seems like it's fine in this
situation and the world seems on paper
that it's in good shape.
But then the market and your stocks get
slammed and you take really heavy losses,
wiping out most of your previous gains or
even worse, you completely blow up your
trading account.
And this is why it's so important to be on
top of macroeconomic factors, not just in
an attempt to predict future moves in the
stock market and future economic growth
and earnings.
But also, if there's an unexpected
macroeconomic shift, you need to be on top
of it so you know what to do.
What would you do in that situation?
Well, you'd preempt it from a risk
management perspective.
You would shift your portfolio bias
quickly and you'd probably shift what you
are actually long and what you are
actually short in your portfolio.
So there would be a composition change in
the portfolio and a directional change in
the portfolio as well.
And this is why it's so important to be on
top of these macroeconomic numbers.
The same, by the way, also happens in bear
markets when you're net short and
macroeconomic expectations shift from,
say, contraction or slowdown to positive
or higher than expected growth.
In that situation, also, if you're on top
of your macroeconomic numbers, you
understand what's going on.
You will change your portfolio bias and
change the composition of your portfolio.
So in an overall pro-trader systematic
process, we must always be on top of the
macroeconomic picture and outlook so we
can change our portfolio bias and
potentially the composition as and when
it's required to do so.
Not only to protect ourselves against the
unexpected, but also to make money from
the moves.
So what we're doing is here is we're
combining the macroeconomic with the
microeconomic to enable trade idea
generation, which taken together with a
timing appraisal, trade structuring and
preemptive risk management in place
enables the creation of the economy.
We're using the creation of a long short
portfolio with a 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
And we're using microeconomic fundamentals
to obtain a micro view on stocks and
sectors within the market.
Marrying the macro and the micro together
gives us the edge that we need to allocate
our dollars with confidence in our ideas
and positions.
The fundamental process or part of the
overall pro-trader systematic process is
microeconomic fundamentals, which is all
quantitative, plus microeconomic
fundamentals, which is both quantitative
and qualitative.
And this is the vast majority of work that
we do as professionally trained traders
and makes up the vast majority of a
pro-systematic framework.
And therefore, it makes up the vast
majority of the professional trading
masterclass video series.
Now, in the next section of the PTM video
series, you're going to learn the
fundamentals of long short portfolio
management.
Then we're going to move on to
microeconomic quantitative and qualitative
processes that are required for trade idea
generation.
Now, as we are at a juncture in the PTM
video series, we're obviously leading
indicators now.
It's very important to never forget the
objective.
The objective is to provide a framework
here that allows retail traders to emulate
consistently profitable professional
traders so you can benefit from the same
approach.
In aiming to make you guys consistently
profitable, the framework must allow you
to utilize the same approach taken by guys
like us by consistently profitable
professional traders, but in your own
retail brokerage accounts.
And it must allow you to implement the
process within the framework on a regular
weekly basis and realistically fit this
into your normal everyday lives.
As a reminder, a systematic asset
selection process, which is what we're
going through here in the PTM video
series, is one in which a trader or
investor goes through a series of
processes in order to find trades or
investments that provide a higher
probability of success when compared to
randomness.
And guys, winning at trading in financial
markets is not about the small, tiny
percentage chance of finding one idea that
makes massive returns through randomness.
Winning at trading in financial markets is
generating consistency in returns over
many, many trades.
This means applying a process that is both
repeatable and robust.
What you have to do is fall in love with
the process instead of fantasizing about
this crazy idea of unicorn returns.
Consistency in returns, if you fall in
love with the process, will occur.
Now, obviously, generating consistency in
returns requires implementation with real
money.
And that is when a trader becomes
unconsciously competent.
This is when you are on autopilot and at
the professional level.
And if you remember our four steps of
learning applied to trading, so the
competency hierarchy.
You've now come out of unconscious
incompetence.
Why?
Because you're doing the PTM video series.
You are now at the level of conscious
incompetence, where you can see literally
throughout the video series that you now
have the right information to enable
learning and application.
Competence comes later when you're
actually implementing and then targeting
consistent returns.
And not only just simply targeting
consistent returns, but actually getting
them.
And that's when you get into the level of
unconscious competence.
So we obviously have a lot of information
still to get through in the PTM video
series.
We've covered a lot of information and
we've covered only leading indicators so
far.
And if you think of what we've learned so
far from leading indicators and understand
it in the context of our ITPM principles.
If you remember the self-starter
mentality, what are we going to be doing
on a regular basis?
Well, we're going to be analyzing business
cycles and their moving parts, firstly,
throughout history.
And we're going to become students of
business cycle history on a continuous
basis.
We're going to be utilizing leading
indicators in conjunction with each other
to get a picture of the economy for
portfolio direction.
Our data collection and investigation, so
learning about money markets and surveys
and how they work in detail to get an
appreciation of what the numbers mean is
very, very important.
Why? Because when you analyze the data,
you will have an edge over those who
actually have no idea.
So we're talking about here, the
unconsciously incompetent.
You can then predict the future and get
positioned for the future when others
can't or don't.
That's where your edge comes in.
Now, obviously, interpretation of the
numbers is way more important than just
knowing what the number is.
There's no point in sitting here on a
regular basis and just looking at the
numbers coming out in money markets and
surveys,
not interpreting the numbers, going
through the data and figuring out what it
all means and how it fits in to the big
picture context.
If you just look at the numbers and do no
further work, you're not going to
understand it.
You're not going to interpret it and
you're not going to act on it.
So we have to be self starters.
We have to be self sustainable.
We have to have a solid work ethic.
We have to glean as much information as
possible from our free resources.
And we have to work smart, not hard.
So being self sustainable, do your own
work, generate your own ideas.
No copy trading.
With work ethic, put your passion to one
side.
On a regular basis, you have to work, be
conscientious and regularly implement the
processes.
From our free resources, you can see so
far in the video series and it will occur
throughout the video series.
Everything you have seen is literally free
information, but interpretation of the
information is the key.
So you act on it with confidence.
And of course, work smart, not hard.
Focus on what matters.
Eliminate the 97% of BS and noise.
Process efficiently and just make money.
You are now moving up the competency
hierarchy and there's still a lot more
work to do.
So now guys, we're going to move on to a
very technical part of the video series.
We're going to be covering foundations of
portfolio management.
So let's go over to the next video and get
started.
you